you know how i make a lot of money
non-qualifying assumable mortgage
you want me to school you on that yeah
cause i'm gonna school people on this
they're gonna flip out
what's it called again non-qualifying
assumable mortgages
okay so let me tell you how this works
so i bought a property in tampa florida
i'm not going to give you the dress
because i could if i want to but i'll
let them holler at me
so i bought a property in january 7th
2020
pre-kovy it was 1.8 acres of dirt on
armenia
avenue all right it was two folios
so i gave the lady 825 g's i gave her
170 000 down
right so i had a non-qualifying
assumable mortgage
with a three-year a five-year balloon at
three percent interest only let me say
what that means
so you know when you go get a loan they
want to check your credentials
they want to see where you work they
want to check your credit yeah they want
to see if you could afford the mortgage
so how i do it let's say i'm buying off
danny right danny i'm gonna buy this
house off you for three hundred thousand
here's a hundred thousand down so the
hundred g's
is ringing bells in their head because
you're already studying the
seller the place is junk they ain't got
no money to fix it
they all back taxes they're hit they're
done
you feel me and no person can get a
retail loan on this dump
because they can't afford to fix it so
the only other people are gonna come in
are cash crooks they're gonna want to
pay her two something right
so i come in is i look at the land if i
can split the dirt and do something else
with that dirt
and i got a non-qualifying paper i'm
gonna eat on both sides
i'm gonna eating the front and the back
i'm gonna eat in the middle too and i'll
show you how to do that
so anyway getting back to this i give
you a hundred on 300 right
so you give me i i create a mortgage and
i give
i try to get interest only interest only
is always the best
for short-term flips because think about
if you're born 200 yeah but it's hard to
get
interest-only loans bro yeah but i'm not
dealing with a bank i'm dealing with a
seller [ __ ] this is you
you can get interested i'm gonna school
you for free
i'm gonna tell you how to do i'm gonna
tell you who to talk like
why would you ever mention a bank the
person that's lending me the money is
the seller
oh the seller's letting you money of
course the seller
draw it up listen to me the seller this
seller's broke
he ain't got no money yeah but i'm
already looking on when to data i'm
going
i'm looking at their i'm looking to see
if they got mortgages
so i'm already working with the seller
you feel me so this guy got a piece of
garbage
that he wants 300 or 400 i'm gonna try
to get it
where i could put a little money out of
my pocket and they give me the mortgage
they become the note holder the seller
becomes the note holder okay
you understand me now i understand i
have many deals like this
this deal i'm selling the seller's a no
holder so look
you get the seller to hold the note okay
and how you do a non-qualifying
assumable mortgage
is like this so what hello sure
fifth grade questions ask kindergarten
questions all right kindergarten
question this is this is
this may sound dumb but if it's a
non-qualifying assumable loan
so this guy owns this house for 300
grand he owns it free and clear
he the seller has no debt what if the
seller does have a loan but then i have
to give him enough down to pay his debt
off
i have to understand his debt okay so
okay so if he doesn't have a loan on the
house
you're paying him monthly and he's
holding the note exactly he's my
mortgage holder okay
so what non-qualifying assumable you
want me to tell you why i do that
so if i want to if i buy it from you and
i want to sell it to him
he doesn't need to qualify for this
mortgage because my
seller is holding a note for me and i'm
allowed to throw that note on
anybody i want you could be doing a bid
in prison i could give it to you
you could be mickey mouse it don't
matter i'm gonna let you're gonna take
my mortgage over it you get it
so i'm buying it for you for 300 and i'm
giving you 100 g's down i'm out of
pocket
like 105 000 because i'm gonna pay net
to seller right because most of these
people they don't want to pay closing
costs
okay so i'm gonna pay the doc stamps the
title insurance blah blah blah right
right the only thing they're gonna pay
is the back taxes right so i'm gonna buy
the property
so now i'm gonna push it on the block
but i already know i'm gonna sell it
otherwise i ain't gonna buy it
i already know i could redump it to
somebody else right right right okay
so i stepped to him i'm like no joe just
give me 375.
give me a buck 75 down take over this
200
3 interest only amortized over 20 years
if they want to do principal and
interest you want a heavy amortization
because you want that payment to be low
so you can rent it or do what you got to
do with little bread out of your pocket
you understand all right so then you
re-push it you make your money and you
walk
that's better than paying cash because
now you can leverage your money multiple
times do you understand what i'm saying
kinda okay look you own the house no no
i get i mean i get the part where
i get the part where you gave the guy a
hundred it's worth three hundred you got
you worth five hundred i'm giving him
three
because a piece of garbage it needs work
right i already know i could push it to
him for 375.
and he don't got he don't got all the
bread because he don't want to go to a
hard money lender right because i told
you before
it's hard to make money with hard money
because they're going to hit you with
two three points right they're gonna
want twelve percent right and they're
gonna want a year balloon
meanwhile you can't even get it done in
a year so you need to have control
so i'm gonna get you to give me a loan
where i could hold you can hold my paper
and i can flip it to this dude okay and
how's this dude buying it cash
no he's gonna give me the 175 375. my
100 i put down
plus another 75. so i just made 75 on a
honey
oh and i'm out yeah now you deal with
this and now they're
now they're just assuming they'll dump
he's taking my note now he's getting
where
oh that's simple that's simple bro
exactly
let me tell you another way one second
aidan is he in frame right now
yeah okay i'm gonna tell you another way
i should make money i used to buy
junkers for like let's just say i buy a
piece of junk house
you can't do this no more cause the
market's changed right but i used to
hold paper too
so i buy this house for 50 g's right so
i buy it for 50
i sell to you for 75. i just made 50
right
yeah wrong here's why i bought it for 50
i sold to him for 75 he gives me 20 g's
down right
so he owes me 55 but i'm gonna charge
him five points
so he's gonna give me another twenty
seven hundred fifty dollars for points
so he's gonna owe me fifty seven
thousand five hundred dollars
at twelve percent but i only got really
thirty g's in this
so he owes me fifty seven five on thirty
at twelve percent so point a month
so now he's paying me another 575. you
understand me so far yeah
so then i go and sell this first note i
saw this first note
to a mortgage buyer i'm like yo he owes
me 57 fired 12
give me 55. so i sell it to the mortgage
i sell to
now i'm done and i just made do the
numbers
55 plus 25 plus i made 20 some g's
basically on nothing because i sold him
the crib
and i dumped the mortgage that's some
slick [ __ ] that's how you got to do
it you got to know how to push the paper
then also you got to do is you got to
learn how to buy houses with double lots
because right now my money's in land i
bought a property the other day for 245
000
3 acres in tampa i got it i tore the
house down
i got a s1 variance to get 60 houses on
it apartments
now i'm dumping it for 900. i'm in it
for three
yeah some lost though they won't even
let you split i tried buying a lot a
couple months ago and they were saying i
was trying because it was huge
and i wanted to build two houses on i'm
like i could build two houses on this
like triple my money quadruple my money
like
i call the county nope not a lot
displayed but you have to understand
the future land use and you have to
understand so look like i don't really
know much about this because i live in
tampa and everything i do is mostly in
tampa
so they have still some land out there
too very
yes exactly not over here but look like
a safety harbor i'm looking a house
guy's got a motel
eight doors with a little cottage he
wants 1.2 i offered him a mill with 500
down
and he's like nah nah i'm not with this
all right give me up but whatever my
point is if i buy that
i'll get back to what i'm talking about
because i know i'm i'm off track
but look the way to make money is you
have to understand how to split the land
once you buy the land you split it and
then they have future land use
so let's pretend the highest density is
cmu 35 let's just pretend
the commercial used 35 per acre so that
means
every acre you could put 35 doors right
so there's a big necessity right now for
affordable housing
because there's so many broke people the
government needs to pay
to build and they got all these tax
credits
i'm selling houses this guy rent this
property he's going to get tax credits
to pay for it for free
and and and the guy's like he's talking
to my realtor why he don't do that
i paid i'm making money i don't care
about all that i'm not looking i don't
want my legacy tell my kids
yo peep this daddy made money cause the
government paid me
what are you bugging what's wrong with
that bro because i'm not with that
why because i like to get my money on
the crying you feel me
that's what motivates you of course i'm
not looking for a welfare check
you ever see that movie with um
[ __ ] take it man i'm not with that
i'm not with that you know why
cause let's pretend you're on your
deathbed and you got all your peeps with
you right yeah
yo remember we did this yeah you
remember the section they paid me
you remember i got a free check who's
gonna look at it use a stunt dummy
remember we got that trump check
but you feel me though the way the way i
look at it is like this
how can i figure it out how could i how
could i game the game
i